In an October 2025 announcement, Wizards
of the Coast floated the idea of a
change to the way hybrid mana is treated
in the deck building rules of EDH. This
caused quite a lot of discourse, which I
laid out some thoughts to in a previous
video that was uncontroversial and
universally beloved by the EDH
community. However, that October 2025
announcement also featured some other
things. One of which was the proposing
of the banning of wristic study, the
powerful blue draw engine. That
particular card has been in a perpetual
state of low-level controversy for some
years now, being both the third most
widely played blue card, but also the
second most hated blue card according to
salt polls conducted by EDHRE. And I
won't bury the lead here. I don't like
this card, and I absolutely think it
should be banned. However, my reasons
for thinking that are different than
those of a lot of people. And I actually
think that this card and the discourse
around it is a fascinating window into
some of the grittier instincts of EDH
players, the ones we don't like to think
about or talk about. At the end of the
day, Rristic study's power level is
certainly quite high, but the
destructive social dynamics it creates
are the more pernicious element of the
card, and these two factors combine to
make it a card that absolutely warrants
a ban. To start with, though, we need to
understand what it is we're talking
about. Why is it that a card should be
banned in EDH? After all, it's a casual
format. A lot of the usual rules of
tournament frequency and meta dominance
don't really apply. We can look at the
current ban list as well as other
actions taken against specific cards to
start to paint a picture. I choose to
begin in a familiar place. Euro the
Tiger's Shadow is a card that spent 7
months on the game changers list last
year. It was eventually delisted under
the reasoning that a rule zero tool like
the game changers list is far less
necessary for policing commander cards
which are visible at the outset of a
game. But Euro still works nicely as an
example of a card that sometimes feels
problematic in EDH. As I laid out a
couple months ago, Euro feeling
problematic comes down to two things.
For one, she is efficient and powerful,
being very cheap to play and providing a
ton of utility through her mixture of
damage and card draw. Secondly, her play
pattern is frustrating. Since her
commander njutsu ability dodges
commander attacks, it is quite hard to
keep her off the board and it often
feels like the Euro player effectively
gets to cheat the normal rules of the
format. So, these are typically the two
things required to make a card truly
problematic. A high power level and a
play pattern that is frustrating. We can
see this echoed in some cards on the ban
list. Whole breacher and leavolt are
efficiently costed creatures and they
also easily combine with wheels to blast
away opposing hands. Primeval Titan and
15 mana emercle are both highquality
bombs that would see wide play if legal
and their abilities also let their
controller rapidly snowball and end up
playing a lot more magic than opponents.
We can even see this in the fast mana
bands of 2024. Manac Crypt and Jeweled
Lotus are obviously very powerful, and
the fact that they allow such explosive
turn one plays can be frustrating and
disempowering for opponents in a way
that some other powerful cards might not
be. Not everything currently on the ban
list or the game changanger list
perfectly fits this framework, but this
power level plus play pattern pairing is
still a decently reliable template. For
something to be worth banning in EDH in
the year of our Lord 2026, it needs to
be frustrating in a way that creates bad
experiences for people. And it also
needs to be powerful enough to see wide
play and make that bad experience
commonplace so as to actually warrant a
ban rather than just being an occasional
annoyance. As we will see shortly,
wristic study checks both of these
boxes. To start with, let's talk power
level. On an objective level, rristic
study's power level is quite high. And
this is evident in the fact that it's
one of the best cards in CEDH. Surely
these expert gamers know how to play
around this bad boy, right? But no,
wristic study is quite powerful even if
all your opponents are being tactical
about paying the one. If somebody wants
to cast a piece of interaction that
spends all their mana, they're not going
to be paying the one. If somebody has a
pivotal play on their turn and no extra
mana to pay, the correct choice is to
play the card and let the rristic study
player draw, not to skip your own turn.
There are all sorts of cases in which it
is absolutely the correct choice not to
pay the one. And that makes wristic
study a pretty great draw engine on
base. Now, as you move down in power
level, decks will get a bit less lean,
have spare mana a bit more often, and
cast fewer overall spells each turn. If
I'm being generous, I think this is
where a lot of people get the idea that
wristic study isn't really problematic.
After all, it does scale with power
level to some extent, especially when we
consider that the maximum card draw in a
game with three spells per player per
turn cycle is significantly more than in
a game with one to two spells per player
per turn cycle. However, this still
misses some things. For one, at bracket
3, cards are going to cost more mana
typically. Whereas an engine in CEDH
might be two or three mana, it's pretty
common to see engines in bracket 3 that
cost four or five mana. And if you only
have four or five mana to work with, one
of these cards is going to be much more
possible to pay the tax on than the
other. This is true for engines, and it
also certainly applies to removal. A lot
of people will make the argument that
wristic study can be answered by simply
removing it. But this misses two key
things. For one, you can say this about
basically any problematic permanent, but
there are still very good reasons to ban
permanence. Profit of Cruix is a pitily
little creature that can be removed far
more easily than wristic study, but
there are still very good reasons for it
to stay banned. Just remove it is a
strategy you can employ, just as making
somebody the archeneemy is a strategy
you can employ. But neither of these
things are arguments to keep a card
legal on the scale of a formatwide ban
list. Secondly, any removal spells cast
on wristic study are themselves wristic
taxed. Best case scenario, it costs an
opponent a mana. But if the removal
isn't super mana cheap, there's a good
chance that the wristic studying player
will get a card as well. And that's all
assuming that the blue player isn't
prepared to play counter spells in
defense of their copy of the most
powerful draw engine in the format. In
the land of reality, counter spells
frequently are present. and any
multispell fight over whether a wristic
study stays on board will often itself
draw the studying player a lot of cards.
There are also people who will downplay
the severity of a rristic study sticking
around on board. A lot of pro- rristic
folks will casually present wristic
study as a one-sided sphere of
resistance. Like come on, bro. If you
just pay the one, it's only three mana
to make all opposing spells cost one
more attacks tool more powerful than any
other that has ever existed. It's not
that bad. This is just patently absurd.
A three mana one-sided sphere of
resistance is obviously good and there's
a reason grand arbiter Augustine IV is
such a salty card even as a four- mana
multiolor card. I think all of what I
just said is pretty reasonable, but I
also worry that my engaging with the
one-sided sphere of resistance talk
legitimizes it in a way that it
absolutely does not deserve. Wristic
study would be an extremely powerful
magic card if it was a one-sided sphere
of resistance, but it is not that. And
this is where this video is going to
really start to diverge from most
critiques of the card I've seen. To
start with, let's just establish that
people will inevitably end up giving the
studying player cards for any number of
reasons. I laid out a couple reasons
earlier that frequently apply to CEDH.
And these reasons arguably strengthen at
lower levels. Just pay the one can be a
sensible strategy when a deck features
highquality plays at multiple mana
values. Like if you're forced to play a
three mana ramp spell instead of a four
mana amplifier, that might not really be
a huge hit to your game plan. On the
other hand, if your deck has a wider
spread of mana values and card effects,
paying the one could keep you away from
a critical play that you really need on
a particular turn. This effect is
further amplified when there are power
level differences present. If one player
has a deck that is less tuned, whose
ramp isn't as well calibrated, and whose
plays are less mana efficient, that
player is going to be hit harder by the
wristic study tax. Ditto for somebody
who gets unlucky or keeps a subpar hand.
Anyone who misses land drops or fumbles
their setup turns is going to be much
less able to spare mana for wristic
study, and being pressured to do so on a
critical turn might, in one fell swoop,
destroy any chance they had of catching
back up. I say pressure because wristic
study-esque effects frequently come with
a dose of social pressure not to feed
the studying player too many resources.
This fact can feel pretty reasonable on
the surface, but this pressure to pay
will be experienced very differently by
different players. The players most
harmed by needing to pay an extra one
for their spells will be on average the
less experienced players piloting the
less powerful decks and getting less
lucky. And whether or not these players
are pushed into ruining their own game
plan may come down to how they react to
the social forces at play. With this in
mind, the just pay the one lol crowd
starts to appear in a somewhat different
light. In a weird way, arguments in
defensiveistic study often end up very
similar to conservative economic
arguments in favor of the status quo.
Hear me out on this one. Let's imagine
somebody trying to introduce a policy in
a society with a lot of economic
inequality. John allocation says we
should implement my tax credit plan as
it will give all the people of this
great nation more of a fighting chance
at succeeding in this economy and
joining the middle class. This is an
economic argument and whether it's
likely to do what Jon says it will do
can be determined by digging into the
details, running some models and
whatever else economists do. Now let's
imagine Jon's political rival has
something to say about that. Jeff
Business says this economy already gives
citizens a fighting chance at joining
the middle class. Just look at all the
hardworking people who have already
succeeded in a society with a lot of
inequality. This is not an economic
argument. This is a moral argument. The
people currently below the middle class
indisputably exist. And rather than
asking why that is or what can be done
to help them, Jeff Business is instead
choosing to turn them into an out group
to be ignored. His implied message is
that there is something wrong with the
people who are currently poor. That they
are less deserving. That they have been
given opportunities and squandered them.
that they have earned their shaken life.
It wouldn't matter if John Allocation's
tax credit had been highly successful at
helping people elsewhere in the world.
Here it would be disrupting a divine
order that has put this pathetic out
group in their correct place. It is an
argument in favor of human suffering
based on the idea that those people have
earned that suffering and no longer
deserve our consideration. When somebody
says wristic study isn't that good,
people just need to pay the one. They're
making a very similar argument, if a
less consequential one, not saying
they're identical, nor that these are
patterns of thought held by all rristic
study defenders, or all conservatives
for that matter, but there's a strong
resemblance. What I mean by that is
this. If telling everybody to just pay
the one was actually a successful
strategy for making wristic study a fair
and enjoyable Magic card, we wouldn't be
having this conversation. The fact that
it's not a solution, that it's an
unhelpful thing to say is already proven
by the observable facts that surround
us. Namely, that rristic study is a very
powerful card at all levels of EDH.
Every day, thousands of Magic players
don't pay the one, and there are a
variety of different reasons for that.
As I suggested earlier, some of them are
playing a weak deck or having a weak
game with their deck, and playing a
couple cards into the wristic study is
the only way to keep up. Or maybe
they're newer to the game and don't have
a firm grasp on the power level of an
engine like wristic study, as suggested
by the trinket mage in his video on the
subject. Maybe they're overwhelmed by
the current state of the game and choose
to go about their turns ignoring wristic
study for that reason, only paying when
doing so is a convenient afterthought.
Maybe somebody sees other players not
paying the one for any of the previous
reasons and decides that it's time for
them to stop paying as well. This is the
reality of wristic study, not the quippy
hypothetical of a smug power gamer. You
can make some sort of argument toward
educating people about playing against
the card, just as an economic
conservative might meekly gesture toward
the importance of teaching people to
budget. But all four of the situations I
described earlier will continue to exist
no matter how high a rooftop you yell
just pay the one from. Ristic study is
fine. People just need to pay the one is
not an argument about game balance. It
is a moral argument about the people
currently not paying the one. So, if
saying just pay the one isn't a helpful
solution to the problem of wristic
study, why do people say it? Well, one
answer to this is pretty simple. Taking
this stance solidifies hierarchies in
the EDH community in a way that some
people find emotionally satisfying. It
forges an in-group to be a part of,
genius gamers who understand riskic
study, and an outroup to be scorned,
everybody else. On a basic level, this
is kind of inevitable. Tribalism is a
folly pretty inherent to being human.
And the fact that it shows up in a card
game whose formats are traditionally
competitive isn't much of a surprise.
Where things start to get hairy is when
these sorts of social forces worm their
way into the basic operation of a
commander game. And this is precisely
what rristic study encourages. Players
not paying, a thing that happens
frequently for a wide variety of
reasons, can become treated as a crime,
punishable in-game and out of game.
Frustrations grow. Resentments smolder.
A game ends up feeling unsatisfying for
one reason or another. One player's
attempt to have any shot at their own
game plan working suddenly gets seen as
them handing the game to another player
out of their own foolishness. And they
are often derided as such. And you know
what? Sometimes those deriders are
right. Many aistic studying player has
been brought to victory through the
power of opponents feeding them too many
cards. But the line here is blurry. The
difference between a player handing
another the win and a player just trying
to play the game they showed up to play,
just trying not to fall too far behind
in tempo to have any shot, it can be
pretty ambiguous. However, acknowledging
that ambiguity, acknowledging that
wristic study frequently puts opponents
in a lose-lose scenario where even the
quote unquote correct choice isn't all
that correct, well, it makes it too
obvious just how powerful the card is.
This is precisely why a lot of wristic
study defenders frame the issue in such
black and white terms. If they spoke to
the reality of the card, it would be
clear why it's such an outlier in the
EDH format. So, this is my ultimate
issue with the card. It applies to the
most basic of game actions, casting a
spell, and turns the game into a maze of
social pressure. From the perspective of
somebody playing against it in a decent
position, you can watch as your
opponents all but hand the risk studying
player a win. And from the perspective
of somebody struggling in that game, you
might be presented with a choice between
attracting the eyeire of your
non-studying opponents and not really
getting to meaningfully play the game.
I've heard some people describe it as a
political tool, but really it's the
opposite of most political tools.
Instead of encouraging players to
collaborate and make deals, it divides
opponents and gets them to foster
resentments amongst each other. One
natural counter-argument that you might
be getting ready to type right now is
that this can be a fun dynamic for a
card to create. And I get where you're
coming from. Prisoner's Dilemma is a
decently popular damage spell for a
reason. Sewing discord amongst your
opponents can be a pretty good time. And
I can't say there isn't something a
little delightful about a blood feud
being declared by a player who just took
12. However, you might remember that
rristic studies social dynamics are only
part of my case for why it should be
banned, with that other part being its
power level. A disorder creating card at
a very high power level is quite a
different story from one at a lower
power. The stakes are quite high due to
the card's extremely high power level
and as a result wristic study sews
resentments forges in groups and
outroups and intensifies the information
density of the EDH format at a rate of
no other card. It also shouldn't go
unmentioned that the power level of
rristic study leads to it being played
quite frequently even with its
gamechanger status in addition to having
massive implications for any game it
exists in. This power level plus
disorder interaction also manifests
especially brutally for wristic study
because it lacks the intentionality of
an actual politics card. The player base
at large isn't running this card because
they have a blast with its play
patterns. They play it because it draws
them a metric shitload of cards and the
negative play experiences swed by the
card are an incidental side effect. If
you remember my Malfagore video, this is
very similar to the reason I dislike the
play pattern of Turrid decks. The
oppressive tools Turrid encourages end
up being impassive engine fodder rather
than tactically deployed instruments
meant to handle the actual situation a
player finds themselves in. And this
ends up turning the destruction of
opposing game plans into a frivolous
side effect. Play patterns like this
alienate players from the effects of
what they're playing, replacing the
tangibility of process and intent with
something simpler and bleeer, the means
to a powerful end. As with just pay the
one lol, appealing to the supposed
fascinating political implications of
riskic study is usually just a smokeokc
screen to conceal the true more basic
motivations at play. So in conclusion,
yes, rristic study should be banned.
There's a solid argument that smothering
tithe should join it as another card
that rapidly generates resources off of
opponents taking basic game actions, but
I won't delve more into that here. What
I do want to discuss is the other camp
of wristic study defenders. basically
just the people saying this card
shouldn't be banned because it's a
popular and iconic part of the format. I
unfortunately can't really attack the
topmost level of this argument. If
within your prefrontal cortex lives the
unshakable axiom that popular cards
should stay unbanned, there's not a
whole lot I can say to change your mind
on wristic study. What I can say is I
find the underlying assumption that
popularity and iconicness should
influence banability to be a little
strange. Firstly, wristic study is
iconic in large part due to how
unpleasant many people find it. Do you
pay the one is an annoying thing to hear
dozens of times, obviously. Regarding
its popularity, I find this a bit odd as
well since a card needs to be some level
of popular to actually affect a lot of
EDH games to be worth banning in the
first place. You could make a card
called Smoogle's Snotgun that's the most
annoying thing to ever exist, but it
wouldn't be worth banning if only 12
people end up playing it. Things get
even weirder when we dig into the
implications of the popularity argument.
One explanation for why rristic study is
so popular is that it's a very powerful
card that wasn't banned by the RC at any
point in the first couple decades of the
format. This is interesting when we
consider that another card, Primeval
Titan, was banned 15 months after it was
printed. And if it hadn't been banned,
it would likely be an even more popular
and even more iconic card than wristic
study. So, what do we make of that? In
that alternate reality, would it be
wrong to ban prime time now? Are all
band decisions effectively being left up
to whatever the RC wanted to do a decade
or two ago back when the format was
largely a charming and slow-paced
sideshow to other Magic events? It's
just a very strange way to justify the
decisions we're making in 2026.
All this to say, the popularity or
iconicness of a card should not be our
primary concerns when it comes to the
EDH ban list. These are understandable
things to care about for somebody who
produces Magic the Gathering content,
who is intimately tied in with the
tropes and the mythos and the parex that
surrounds the game. But those things are
not the commander format. Commander
games are the commander format, and we
should be concerned with how a card
impacts real EDH games that millions of
people play. Does it have a positive
impact to improve the experience of
people playing this game or does it do
the opposite? What is the extent of that
impact? How widespread? These are the
actual questions worth asking about risk
study and I hope I've done an adequate
job giving my answer to them in this
video. Thanks for watching and thanks to
Architect for supporting the channel.
Architect is my deck building website of
choice, and one thing I like about it is
how smoothly it integrates EDHX salt
scores into its design, letting you
easily see both individual card salt
scores and the aggregate salt score of a
deck. A link to all of my decks is down
in the description. Also supporting the
channel is Dragon Shield. You can get
yourself durable sleeves in a fabulously
wide range of colors at my affiliate
link down in the description, and you'll
be helping out the channel in the
process. Finally, big shout out to my
supporters on Patreon and YouTube who
give me the freedom to make 20-minute
video essays about why I hate a specific
card with my whole being. If you join,
you'll get to vote on what card I essay
should be banned in my next video. Okay,
that was a joke. Unless.